Theresa May is going to be making a
speech today on anti-terror legislation
going into Parliament she's going to say
we're facing one of the greatest threats
of all times because the number of
British jihad is in Syria and Iraq among
the new measures is a plan to try and
crack down on ransom payments to terror
groups is have said to have got 28
million pounds this way over the past
year under the new rules insurance
companies won't be able to cover
payments which should really close a
loophole that has allowed some people to
pay ransoms in the past they're also
going to ask Internet companies to keep
more data which will allow them to try
and identify the individuals who own
phones and computers where there might
be suspicious activity and then plans
that the Prime Minister has already
announced will be pushed through
Parliament the power to relocate
suspects across the country sees
passports and also ask airlines to
provide passenger information Theresa
May says she would go further if it
wasn't for the lib dems and we'll hear
from Nick Clegg at his monthly press
conference today on that issue EU and
immigration not gone away Owen paterson
the former Environment Secretary
speaking today saying that Britain
should actually tell Europe it's ready
to leave and then have a two year
renegotiation period as long as you keep
keep marching this is something that
isn't going to go away soon